allergy season is in full bloom and if
you are ready for some relief it is time
to call zerorez and joining me to tell
us more is owner and general manager of
las vegas zerorez ben mckee welcome
it is so good to have you here because
my allergies are driving me crazy and i
know zerorez is here to help that's
right you know we i always get asked
like are our carpets really the biggest
air filter in our homes or other
businesses and they really are i brought
a little treat today okay what's in this
so this is this cup has
just dry particularly that it came out
of my house out of a carpet at my house
and i it's even after i vacuumed so i
don't know if you can see it on the
camera it's just a bunch of dirt and i
see a leaf in there a little rock this
is stuff that was hiding this probably
blew in a little bit later but
it's just tons of sand that a vacuum
cleaner just cannot pick up but our zero
res process we're able to help remove
that stuff so your carpets stay cleaner
longer and you wonder why you're
sniffling and sneezing all this stuff is
in your carpet and zerorez can help get
rid of that
you don't use soap and you don't use
chemicals though so how does that work
exactly you know our secret our
methodology is we clean with what we
call zr water technology and this is
it's just water that we have we've
harnessed the power that water already
has we've raised the ph of it it's
completely safe
but it's extremely effective at getting
your flooring cleaned and it works more
than just carpets i mean we can use this
on thailand grout upholstery you name it
we got you covered all right well let's
let's see
the man with the plan in charge you got
i mean you've got a big job ahead of you
and if you see this dirty mess we've got
that dry particulate in there
and that's
gone like that that didn't even take a
second
but now we have
all this other stuff how is this even
possible i call it one swipe magic here
it's amazing and you can see like we
just want this is a really dirty carpet
so if your carpet looks like this at
home we've got you covered but um but
we're able to get all that dirt that
grease to grime out like you said
without using soaps or harsh chemicals
and my favorite part about it all
there's no weird smells right yes it
doesn't smell bad in here and the carpet
is extremely dry it dries so fast that's
my favorite thing i don't have to wait
24 hours i know i'll be able to walk on
my carpet soon after look at that and
it's so soft too you don't feel that
crunchiness that you usually feel and
that's because we're not using the soaps
and the chemicals that are left behind
with traditional cleaning methods so you
just have clean soft carpets like they
came from the factory now it's not just
carpets though if you have never had
your air filters cleaned before might i
suggest you do that talk a little bit
about that
we clean air ducts i mean our whole
approach is to come in and make your
home or your business a cleaner indoor
air environment
that makes your building or your house
more healthy and hygienic especially
with all this crazy allergies going on
and we've got a top-down per approach
like we're going to come and we can
clean your air ducts and clean your
upholstery your floors anything you've
got we'll get it cleaned up for you this
is why you've been named best of las
vegas how many times i think we're gone
this is number four it's like we're
losing count they're so great so make
sure you call zero res and see why they
are so great and you guys will actually
have a great special right now for our
viewers you can give zero res a call at
702-840-3333
or visit them online at
xerorezlasvegas.com and take advantage
of their spring cleaning special carpets
clean for as low
as 39 per room plus you get free tile
cleaning up to 100 square feet so check
that out